you wanna buy my corned beef sandwich
you know like my sandwich is my music I
don't think that's how friends work
maybe we shouldn't be anymore
we should have been friends
[Music]
food afterwards Thank You April Heather
salmon not hungry mom she's allowed to
be depressed
thank you no one as good as Nikhil ever
love her again because Sarah girl come
from anyway she's like moved here so I'm
just showing her around and you've got
before I show her the Chinese Theatre
she should see next penis hi you're
April uh-huh do you wanna go do a shot
why are you being so nice to me I want a
reason to give you a black eye what
about what he grabbed your boob like a
tightly sealed dick as a Quidditch stick
he hasn't done that with me I think we
should make some rules you're gonna tell
him you were rat Benjamin wouldn't know
what happens to rats they get shaped in
their sleep they get their carbon
monoxide detectors disabled yeah you
guys are perfect for each other you know
that
[Music]
think about you all the time
[Music]
even suited very little personal growth
for you rebounding with it's just like
mr. Karle oh it's not what I meant
you